i want to make a goal of mine publicly
known so that you can hold me to it you
know one of the best ways to actually
get something done is to tell other
people that you plan to do it and my
goal is to stop explaining myself to
idiots now you might say whoa sir that's
very aggressive language what do you
mean
in order to try to save myself
from thousands of horrible comments
tweets and emails i will often over
explain things and give disclaimers and
i really am only doing that
to people who are just nuts or are bad
faith actors so like when i say hey guys
you know in the in the russia ukraine
thing putin's the aggressor but to be
clear i don't support american
imperialism i don't think the u.s is a
perfect actor with an unblemished record
of foreign uh foreign relations i do not
favor the u.s sending troops to ukraine
i do not think the u.s should choose the
leaders in other countries and all of
those disclaimers are really for like
five percent of my audience now i wish
it was like one percent or less but it
is about five percent of the audience
but it's a very loud five percent it's a
very weaponized five percent but most of
you know that i don't mean invade russia
when i say putin is being the aggressor
here and likewise when i say you know
i can't support
the former
chavez now maduro regime in venezuela
because they've raped and pillaged the
country's resources for themselves while
spewing false populist rhetoric about
how they're going to help everybody and
meanwhile people can't even afford food
which there are shortages of anyway
i don't mean invade venezuela i don't
mean assassinate maduro i don't mean
that the u.s should pick who is the
leader in venezuela i only mean
i don't like maduro 95 percent of you
get that but the five percent that don't
or refuse to are really loud and really
annoying but this isn't normal
this isn't a normal way to talk about
things and this is sadly a toxic reality
of the internet this is kind of like how
twitter works and social media
all these platforms select and and
highlight
reactionaries and outrageous responses
to content i'll give you kind of like a
benign example i post a picture of
myself having a cappuccino at a coffee
shop in los angeles the way i did two
months ago this was on instagram not
twitter
99 of the people who see me with my
stupid cappuccino
say nothing i never hear from 99 of the
people who see that picture
one percent leave a comment
90 of the comments are completely normal
weather looks great
looks great have fun yeah whatever okay
of the comments okay so we're talking
ten percent of the one percent the
people who choose to comment of those
comments ten percent people go
crazy
david you're traveling during a pandemic
you're so irresponsible how dare you you
know people died of covet today
the other one
you're not wearing a mask david
si
you don't
you don't care about other people you're
so self-centered that you drink a
cappuccino with no mask
and
number three
are you drinking cow's milk
how are you not a vegan you're a
terrible person
it's not normal and social media really
skews this because
most people see a guy with a coffee and
they move on with their day but the
internet has created this almost
defensive status quo for posting
anything and on my show
i'm in this defensive mode
whenever i comment on stuff even though
anybody normal or acting in good faith
realizes these are not normal reactions
and that i'm not saying
whatever the worst faith possible
interpretation of my words actually is
so my new effort is going to be
not to do the disclaimers and the
defensiveness when i just give my
opinion about things on the show because
at the end of the day
not only is it preposterous to cater
to people who are quite frankly nuts or
bad faith actors it also won't stop them
from saying the exact same things i've
got an example for you look at the
comments on my recent russia clips in
those videos i say putin is the
aggressor
but i'm not an imperialist
i don't want war
i don't want u.s troops there i don't
want u.s involvement beyond you know if
nato as an organization says well we're
gonna support ukraine in some way i
don't want the u.s doing regime change
and i look at the video and i see
comments like the ones i'm i'm putting
up on the screen for you right now
you're just repeating establishment
talking points and neocon lies david i'm
not imperialist but let's have war
now i i did the disclaimers and i still
got the comment next comment you are an
imperialist
no no no i i explained it another
comment tulsi is a twisted grifter but
you're brazenly lying warmongering
imperialist trash david
i'm gonna do my best because either way
they're gonna say that stuff
so at the end of the day
i don't do the show for that crazy five
percent
i'm doing the show for the good faith 95
percent so the other five percent can
quite frankly you know go go to wherever
hold me to it keep me honest okay i
appreciate that